JOSHUA MARANTZ: Good morning,
and welcome to
Make the Web Faster.
Today we're going to bring you
three new technologies.
My name is Joshua Marantz and
I'm going to talk about
mod_pagespeed, which is
an Apache module which
automatically rewrites
web pages to make
them display faster.
Richard Rabbat will talk about
WebP, which is a new image
format for the web.
And Hakon Wium Le will talk
about Opera and WebP.
So, why make your
website fast?
The benefits are many, among
them are user satisfaction--
people like to go to
fast website--
better engagement,
and more revenue.
But it's hard.
The techniques for improving
websites are reasonably
well-known, but they're
cumbersome
to implement manually.
There's trade-offs to make.
There's the trade-off
of maintainability--
of being able to easily change
your website and maintain it--
versus keeping minified versions
and sprites of your
images and your text,
et cetera.
There's an agility trade-off,
because if you set your cache
lifetimes for a long time out,
it's very difficult to change
your JavaScript to fix bugs and
have it push out because
users' browsers have cached
in it an old version.
And if you set the
cache lifetime
short, you get agility.
But then everybody after they
come back to your site, if
they come back on a daily basis
they'll get a fresh
download each time.
So another aspect is that
browsers are moving forward at
a rapid pace.
New browsers have new techniques
that can help web
developers build faster
websites.
But the old browsers lack these
techniques, and you
don't want to leave all the
users who are stuck on old
browsers for various
reasons behind.
You want to continue to support
them well letting new
browsers exploit
the techniques.
So you kind of have to have some
server-side intelligence.
And we're discovering new
techniques all the time.
There's a talk later today about
mobile best practices.
And as these techniques are
learned and adopted adopted
and changed, you want to be able
to have a tool that helps
adopt your website, rather
than employing somebody
full-time to keep up with these
techniques and adjust
your website accordingly.
So the solution is to
use automated tools.
So this is what mod_pagespeed
is for.
Optimize your website without
having to change it.
You don't have to change the way
you generate content, you
don't have to minify your CSS
and your JavaScript by hand
and keep two versions
around, spriting
your images, et cetera.
You don't have to manually run
ImageMagick over your whole
library of photos and keep
two versions of those.
Get a machine to do
that for you.
That's what machines
are good at.
So what does mod_pagespeed do?
It actually does
no black magic.
the techniques for optimizing
webpages, there's basically
two bibles written by Steve
Souders: High Performance
Websites and Even
Faster Websites.
And they are pretty much the
techniques that we use today
in mod_pagespeed to make
your website faster.
Image compression, sizing images
to the right size,
minifying CSS, JavaScript,
and HTML.
We take small images that are
below a certain threshold and
inline them.
Same with CSS and JavaScript.
And probably most importantly,
we extend cache lifetimes, and
we'll talk more about.
All of these techniques
are listed.
We have a demo site called
modpagespeed.com, you go to
that site, it shows you every
optimization that we do,
documentation before
and after.
So here's one example we'll dive
into called combining CSS
files, so if you have four small
CSS files, each one of
these when it's rendered in a
browser would represent a
separate HTTP request. For all
kinds of reasons it's better
to bundle these into one file
and this is not very hard to
do by hand, but it's kind of
hard to maintain over time and
it's kind of a conflict.
So to get a tool to do that
for you, you turn on
mod_pagespeed and the four lines
of links become one link
with a concatenated name.
And one of the most important
things we do is we add to the
concatenated name a hashtag
which is the md5sum of the
content of the file.
And by doing this, that enables
us to serve this
resource, a combined
CSS file, with a
very long cache lifetime.
This means that browsers
will retain
knowledge about this file--
we set the cache lifetime
for a year.
But if you want to go back and
change one of these CSS files
that it's built out of, then
mod_pagespeed will pick up
that change, will recompute the
md5 tag, will serve the
rewritten CSS link with a new
name, and the old stale entry
in the browser cache
doesn't hurt you.
So you kind of get the best of
both worlds, which is a long
cache lifetime but an easily
changeable site.
So how do you bring
mod_pagespeed into your web
server flow?
You have an existing
Apache HTTP server.
You can download from
co.google.com.
Our source code and pilot
where we have pre-built
binaries for CentOS and
DBN and Ubuntu.
And so you pretty much download
into the Apache
server, and now you don't have
to change your content, you
don't have to change your
content generation flow.
You may want to tweak some of
the settings in pagespeed.com,
that's optional.
And you get out of that reduced
latency, improved
bandwidth, and much longer
cache lifetimes.
So taking a peek under the hood,
mod_pagespeed is really
divided into two sections.
There's a platform-independent
rewriting infrastructure, and
it has a whole bunch of pieces
in it, but it's all called
Pagespeed Automatic.
And this is the engine that
rewrites webpages on the fly.
On the right we have a bunch of
plug-ins, which are used to
adapt this architecture to
a specific platform.
And the first deployment
for this technology
is an Apache module.
So we have an Apache module
gasket, and this defines
mechanisms for caching HTTP
content, caching metadata,
fetching resources, threading,
and other assorted tasks. it's
kind of a plug-in architecture
so that this can be applied to
multiple platforms,
but our deployment
initially is Apache HTTP.
How much factor has
this made the web?
So so far, this has been
launched for about six months.
We launched in November
of last year.
A few days after that,
DreamHost, a hosting provider,
made it a push button on
their control panel.
So any DreamHost-hosted site
can push a button and
mod_pagespeed is activated
on their site.
A couple of months later, we
announced with Go Daddy, the
dominant hosting provider--
who has a similar push-button
flow, it's actually a config
file change-- but any Go Daddy
user can enable mod_pagespeed
with, basically, a line
in a config file.
The project is built on a large
base of source code,
including the pagespeed source
code and a lot of Chromium
source code, but we have about
60,000 lines of code that we
wrote ourselves for this.
It's a significant project.
About 54,000 sites have
installed and are running
mod-pagespeed as of today, and
the number is climbing.
So what does mod_pagespeed
do to the sites?
Well, let's take a look at 28
sites that we looked at that
have installed mod_pagespeed.
To test the site, we used a tool
called webpagetest.org.
webpagetest.org is a
client-side testing
technology.
It's built in with
various browsers.
In our case, the browser
that we used was IE8.
So these are all IE8-based
numbers.
And the blue lines indicate
the first time the page is
brought up.
And the red lines indicate the
repeat view, so that's with a
warm cache.
And every website
is different.
We find that a typical
improvement between 20% and
30% is not surprising.
We've seen improvements
as much as 50%.
And this is basically just by
downloading a module and
turning it on.
There are websites that have
already been hand tuned to
follow all the best practices,
basically do the same things
manually that mod_pagespeed
does automatically.
And in that case, we don't
offer much improvement.
In fact, we add some overhead
because we have to go and
parse the website and say,
nope, this is all done.
So let's look at this data from
a different perspective.
Let's look at the images on the
top 1,000 websites on the
web, the Alexa 1,000.
On this corpus of images, a
fairly significant number of
them, mod_pagespeed just looked
at them and said, I can
get rid of a huge percentage
of the bytes.
Over 75% of the bytes.
This would typically happen if
somebody takes a photograph
from a camera and puts it into
a thumbnail on a webpage.
Most of those pixels are not
going to be seen by the user,
so why do you want to
ship them over the
wire all the time?
You get a machine to reduce
that for you.
You don't have to manage that
with compressing it with
ImageMagick yourself, you just
let mod_pagespeed do it.
But a really surprisingly high
number of images can be
improved by a significant
amount, say 20% to 25%.
And these typically come from
just better compression
ratios, or re-encoding color
maps to be more optimal, or
getting rid of all of the
metadata, the f-stop at which
the photograph was
taken, et cetera.
So let's dive into one of the
sites that has installed
mod_pagespeed, called
androidacademy.com.
First of all, we know that
this has installed
mod_pagespeed because when we
look at the HTTP response
headers from that site,
one of them--
the one where the gray
arrow is pointing--
it says x-mod-pagespeed.
So we know that that site was
rewritten by mod_pagespeed.
So we tested this site
webpagetest.org, which
produces a lot of data.
It also produces videos.
So on the left, mod_pagespeed
is off, on the right,
mod_pagespeed is on.
So this a downloaded and go.
In this case, the site is sped
up noticeably by turning
mod_pagespeed on.
But let's go back and
look at the numbers.
So here's some colored bars.
The top colored bars represent
the first view.
The off on the top
and on the below.
And below that, you see
the repeat views.
The first bar, the blue
bar, represents the
time to first byte.
That's the time between when the
browser sent the request
for the HTML file and
the first byte of
HTML that came back.
And you'll notice that when we
turn mod_pagespeed on, we
actually make that take
a little bit longer.
And that's because we've
introduced this server, this
rewriting pipeline
into the flow.
So we've actually added
some processing.
Typically 10 to 30 milliseconds
of delay is added
to that first byte.
But we find so much on most
websites to improve that by
the time you get to the time
to first paint, we've
benefited the site by
close to a second.
By the time you get to the page
load time, the onload
handler, we've benefited the
site by more than two seconds
on the first view.
And on repeat views,
the numbers are
a little bit different.
And the reasons for the
improvement are also
different, and we'll
go into those.
So these are the waterfall
diagrams for this site,
androidacademy.com, that have
been collected and rendered by
webpagetest.org.
On the left mod_pagespeed
is off, on the right
mod_pagespeed is on.
The top ones are first
view and the bottom
ones are repeat view.
And each of the things, you
don't have to zoom very far
into these things and look
at all the data to
understand the story.
On the first view, you'll notice
that the waterfall
diagram is significantly
shorter.
It's probably about 30% shorter
with mod_pagespeed on.
And that's because
of two things.
It's because of inlining
small resources so
there's less HTTP requests.
And it's because of combining
resources, combining multiple
CSS files into one, et cetera.
On the bottom, we have
the repeat view.
I should say the first view
also benefits because we
compress images.
So we make the images smaller,
but it's harder to tell that
by looking at a zoomed out
view of the webpage.
You'd have to look at the
waterfall diagram in a lot
more detail to see that.
But we'll take a look in more
detail at an example where we
can show that later.
So the bottom charts with the
big yellow blobs, those are
the repeat view.
And what those yellow bars mean
is that's called a 304.
That's where the browser has
a copy of the resource--
an image or a CSS file--
but it doesn't know because it
doesn't have a long caching
lifetime or the cache
is expired.
Is this valid or not?
So it has to send a request to
the server saying, hey I've
got this resource.
It's got this hex tag
called an Etag.
Is this one good?
And in this case, during these
tests, it is good.
So the server sends back,
yes, yes, go with that.
And that's a very low bandwidth
request, but it
incurs a complete
roundtrip time.
So with mod_pagespeed off, you
have to do a lot of round
trips to the server, even with
a warm cache, just to make
sure that all these resources
are still valid.
Because we've done cache
extension and added those
hashtags, those md5sums
to every URL.
The browser, if it has the
URL, it's the correct URL
because the content hash
is in the URL.
So that's why the repeat view
waterfall diagram with
mod_pagespeed on looks a
lot more compelling.
So let's take a look at how
we do our measurement.
With webpagetest.org, we
did four runs, which is
mod_pagespeed on and off with
repeat view and first view.
And then we repeat
that 50 times.
And the reason that we repeat
that 50 times is that
measurement on the
web is hard.
If you were to get a stopwatch
and hit the refresh button in
your browser a whole bunch of
times and just write down all
the numbers, you'd see
that there's a
fair amount of variance.
It's kind of hard to do this.
It's a lot easier for machine to
do this, but still there's
a lot of things in between the
client and the server that can
cause variance.
It's a measurement variance.
One of those things
is the network.
In this case, Android Academy is
hosted in England, and our
testing clients were
located in the US.
So we had an intercontinental
delay, which probably added a
fair amount of variance to our
test. And I think that's
probably what accounts for
most of the jitter.
But we have also seen with many
other sites where the
servers are overloaded.
And you'll see the red
and blue dots are
much more of a jumble.
And it's hard, if you were to
just one repeat or three
repeats or something like that,
you could easily draw
the wrong conclusion.
And you have to see a lot
of data for us to
be able to get confident.
So in this case, while there's
a fair amount of jitter, the
improvement is pretty clear.
There's jitter in the
measurement, but the results
are quite clear that
mod_pagespeed has consistently
benefited this site.
So where are we going
with mod_pagespeed
speed down the road?
We are installed on around
60,000 servers.
That's a start, but we'd like to
make the whole web faster,
and not just 60,000 sites.
So we're seeking leveraged ways
to do that-- high volume
partners, hosting
providers, CDNs.
We'd like to encourage leverage
integrations with
servers, proxies, and caches
that could put
this technology inline.
And we saw in the architecture
slide earlier, it's kind of a
plug-in architecture.
So it should be feasible to
integrate this rewriting
technology into other stacks
other than the Apache stack.
And we've just been going all
out trying to support every
user that uses mod_pagespeed.
You can see us on Twitter, you
can see us on our discussions
list, et cetera, trying to get
everybody successful that's
trying to use it.
We'd also like to make the web
more fast. We've been going to
the basic optimizations that are
recommended in the Souders
books that I showed before.
But we're working on things like
image spreading and WebP
integration.
We're going to talk about
WebP in the next
segment of the talk.
We'd like to add deferring
JavaScript execution.
There's a whole suite of things
that we are anxious and
excited to start working on
to make this speed-up more
dramatic than what
we have so far.
It's also important to put
effort into measurement.
We want to measure better.
We have dozens of filters now
that help rewrite web pages.
Which of these have
the most impact?
We'd like to get some
data behind that.
And we'd like to help users
evaluate the benefits for
mod_pagespeed.
The more you're hitting refresh
with a stopwatch, the
more hard it's going
to be to draw
repeatable conclusions from--
we want to enable users to
effectively gauge the benefit
they're getting from
mod_pagespeed.
I want to jump out of the
presentation and show you more
image stuff.
So this is an example
you can do yourself.
This is off of modpagespeed.com.
This is the site I showed
a snapshot of earlier.
This shows you all of the
rewrite passes at
mod_pagespeed supports.
I went into the rewrite
images example.
This is the before picture,
where we have three images.
And this is the source code--
view source, it's probably
not that visible.
So there's a couple of
key points here.
Puzzle.jpg is about
235 kilobytes.
We don't really need
all those bits.
We've displayed it
in a small space.
Why not have the rewritten
puzzle.jpg, which is put into
a 256 by 192 thumbnail.
Which we can serve you in 21
kilobytes, and can you tell
the difference?
In addition to that, besides
making that JPEG a lot smaller
than when you pulled it out of
the camera, one of these
images is sufficiently small.
I think it's this coffee cup.
It's sufficiently small that
we've decided that it's better
to inline it.
So on the on the after page with
mod_pagespeed on, you see
one less line in the
waterfall diagram.
And that's because that coffee
cup has been rendered as a
data URL so that it can be
displayed without having any
additional HTTP requests.
So mod_pagespeed.
It's an open source
Apache module.
It uses an Apache license, which
means you can basically
download the code and do
whatever you like with it.
So it's an open source Apache
module, which automatically
makes your websites faster.
There's two key points here.
One is that it makes your
websites faster by doing these
rewrites for fairly well-known
techniques.
And the other one is that
it's automatic.
Even if you know these
techniques, you might decide
that you don't want to keep
doing them yourself manually
every time you change
your site.
So there's all kinds
of material on
the web about this.
It's easy to search
for it now.
The first place to go is
modpagespeed.com, which shows
all of the places--
all of the rewrites that
we do before and after.
So next up, we have
Richard Rabbat who
will talk about WebP.
RICHARD RABBAT: Thank you.
So before I start talking about
WebP, I want to mention
that when Josh and I started
this project, people were
telling us that we were crazy.
We had this developer tool,
pagespeed, that we've been
innovating with, adding lots
of new best practices, and
trying to understand
how people can
make their pages faster.
And then at some point, we
decided this we should make
this automatic.
We decided that we could try to
spend a lot of engineering
time to make the web developer
not spend time themselves
optimizing their pages, but
instead focusing on their
content and adding delightful
content for your users.
At Google it's kind of
nice, because they
let you try and fail.
If you fail too many
times, they
don't let you try anymore.
But it was just amazing.
When we launched this,
the uptake was--
we were actually not expecting
that people really wanted this
technology in that fashion.
We were very surprised.
It just helped the engineering
team put in more effort.
People put in weekends,
weeknights,
and things like that.
One thing that Josh mentioned,
which is we've been doing a
lot of measurements with things
like webpagetest.org.
And it's a great tool because
you can see what's happening.
But last week--
if you have Google Analytics
on your website, the Google
Analytics team launched a site
speed measurement tool, which
allows you to see the exact
latency that your users
actually experience.
As opposed to when you're under
a controlled environment
from a certain server or
close your server.
So if you use Google Analytics,
you should
definitely add one line of code
and see what your users
are experiencing in
terms of latency.
It may be very eye-opening
for you.
So talking about WebP.
WebP is one of these other
examples of crazy ideas that
we try and we see if
it's going to work.
And as you all know, most of
the images out there are in
JPEG format.
This is one of the Google
logos at some point.
So a JPEG is a lossy format.
GIF has been there for
a very long time.
It has very specific use cases
that people still want to
have. There's the tracking
pixels, which we don't like
talk about.
But there's also things like
transparency and animation.
Gif is great at allowing
you to do transparency.
But also people like small
animations, two or three
images next to each other.
PNG has been used--
portable network graphics-- has
been used for very high
quality icons, texts, graphs,
things like this.
There's an example
a PNG Google I/O.
You want to see a developer
conference, you want to be
able to read the words
"developer conference."
But if you look at webpages--
we all know that an image
is worth a 1,000 words--
and today on the web there's a
lot of bytes that are totally
image bytes.
And you can look at--
this is data from
httparchive.org.
And the HTML bytes that you're
shipping to users are in the
10s of kilobytes, and images
are in the 400 kilobytes.
There's this data from Intel
Corporation that says that
compression hasn't changed over
the past few years, but
there's a lot of CPU
power that people
have on their devices.
Some of you may have gotten
some tab devices today.
Great technology.
The processing technology in
these tablets are way more
advanced than what
you got in a new
supercomputer 10 years ago.
And there's a lot of algorithmic
improvements.
So we decided to try to figure
out if we can propose an image
format that can lead to
better compression
than what JPEG does.
It is based on the VP8
bitstream, which is what's
also used for the web
and video format.
And at first, we did a pretty
large study with
about 900,000 JPEGs.
And if we took them and we tried
to compress them again
for the same signal-to-noise
ratio, we would get about
39.8% better compression.
And we thought, oh maybe it's
just because the JPEGs that
are out there are just
full of extra bytes
that are not be needed.
And basically we did something
we called re-JPEG--
JPEG recompression.
And we could only get 14%
improvement over that.
Recently, we started a new study
which is based on SSIM,
which is considered a better
metric for image quality.
And we took about 26,000 PNGs
and we did a compression at
JPEG quality of 75, we
recompressed for the
equivalent SSIM quality.
We were getting about
40% smaller.
Towards the end of this week or
next week, we're going to
release a much larger study with
some of the images that
people are used to looking at
when they look at image
compression.
Now why is WebP so cool?
If you look at low bitrate
performance--
this is an image that one of
our friends from Wikipedia,
Mathias Schindler tried.
He took a picture of one of
these German senators and
tried to compress at a very low
bitrate in WebP and JPEG.
You can see at low bitrate,
JPEG just
doesn't quite get it.
And at high bitrate, WebP
provides something that's just
as good as a lossless
compression like PNG.
And why do we do WebP?
This is data from, again,
webpagetest.org.
We have this website where we're
comparing a bunch of
images that we put in JPEG
versus a bunch of images that
we put in WebP.
And you can see that some of
the data-- for example, the
fully loaded data--
shows that for WebP, you can
save about three seconds in
time for fully loaded,
because you're
downloading many less parts.
In this case, we're downloading
529 kilobytes,
versus 729 kilobytes.
And it directly impacts the
speed of your webpage loading.
So we started with WebP and we
focused on speed, because that
was going to be the major
feature of the format.
But we also wanted to delight
a lot of our users.
So when we first released it,
people gave us some good
feedback that they wanted
to see a better
encoding of the image.
And we spent a few months, we
improved the encoder itself to
focus specifically
on still images.
The WebM encoder was very
focused on the transitions,
the video stuff.
Instead, with WebP we
focus our encoding
on the still image.
And the feedback is
it's now beating
JPEG much more readily.
So what are we doing next?
A bunch of new features.
We want to support people's need
for metadata, and we're
adding XMP support.
XMP is extensible metadata
platform.
We know some people are used to
XF, but XF has been painful
for lots of people as well,
because there's no
standard around it.
It just creates problems
for the web.
So because this is a format that
we want to have for many
years in the future, we're
focusing on better, cleaner
technology.
Animation.
When we first launched WebP,
we had a lot of comments.
We want animation.
We said, well just use
the video tag.
It's great.
And they're like, no.
So we tried to figure out
exactly why, and it turns out
it's mostly a philosophical
issue as opposed to a
technology issue.
People that like to do
development of animated images
really want to use the typical
software that they're used to,
like their Photoshop,
their ImageMagick.
They don't want to use FFmpeg
for creating animation.
So we're adding this.
And because we're now in a much
newer world, we're adding
3D stereoscopy.
Tiling, because you can have
a bunch of images, you can
create as large of an
image as you'd like.
And you can start displaying
parts of the image as you can
download it.
And there's one cool thing
that we're adding.
Who knows about CSS
background images?
OK.
Who likes how they have
to write them?
OK, thank you.
So if you look at the
third column--
sorry for the colors
a little bit here.
So we're basically grouping
images together and they're
going to have a hashtag.
And image source, for example,
group.webp#john and #jack.
And then instead of having to
figure out exactly at what
coordinates you're going to pick
the image from, you can
actually just refer to
the image within
that multi-image format.
And there won't be any
weird CSS to write.
For 3D-- again, if you look
at the third column--
if you look at 3D images that
are out there that are in
JPEG, if you display them on a
2D display, they just don't
make any sense.
So with our ability to put
multiple images in the same
image file, we can actually call
the left image versus the
right image separately, and
then we can show them.
It depends on what display
technology one is using, and
then you can see you can maybe
downgrade to a 2D for some
people, present 3D for others.
And also use--
it depends on the capabilities
of the device.
But it's definitely an image
format that we're looking at
to grow in the future, so it's
still young and we're adding
some more things.
Last week, one of the engineers
added a JNI
interface, which we
think is cool.
And we're adding lossless so
that we can have better
transparency support.
On the product side, Picasa web
albums, Gmail, and Google
App Engine are adding support.
Picasa web albums already has
it, as well as Gmail.
Google App Engine is going to
have that support soon.
And what you get with WebP is
when you have VP8 hardware
support, you get the WebP
hardware support immediately.
The next release will also
have a much faster codec.
Now that's we have a very good
encoder, we're spending some
time writing assembly code
to make it much faster.
That's it.
And at this point, I'd like to
welcome Hakon to talk about
Opera and WebP.
Thank you.
HAKON WIUM LIE: Perfect,
thank you.
Thank you Richard, thanks
for inviting me here.
I was at Google I/O last year as
well, when the video format
WebM was introduced.
And this is a pleasant follow-up
I think, to be able
to do a still image format.
I have to make one comment
though, you talk about the
weird CSS syntax.
I'm partially to blame for that,
I proposed CSS in 1994,
and my baby has kind of
grown since then.
And I agree with you, that
the background--
the multiple background images
is kind of weird.
But it's also stuff that
we don't really
encourage people to use.
You shouldn't really have
multiple background images on
your elements.
That's only if you want to do
rounded corners or something.
And we actually have to better
properties for that now.
Border radius is there.
So you don't really have to do
the weird CSS thing anyway.
Also, a word of warning.
In this session you will be
hearing a lot about automated
techniques for improving
performance.
And I think that's helpful.
That's why we're doing it.
We're doing it too at Opera.
But there's limits to how far
you can go with that.
You still have to take
responsibility for your HTML
code, for your CSS code,
and for your images.
We can only get so far with
automated techniques.
So we still need bright minds
out there to do the coding.
Given that we do want automated
techniques though,
I'd like to present Opera's
views on those.
And we start sort of
on the other end.
We start not on the server
end, we start with the
clients, with the users.
And probably the product
that many of you know--
we have about 100 million people
using Opera Mini these
days, active users.
Opera Mini is a small client
originally written in Java
that runs in handsets, typically
in mobile phones,
many of them in the
developing world.
And they give internet access,
web access, to ordinary
phones, to ordinary people.
People who don't have
PCs, perhaps.
People who don't have even
the power to run a PC.
And what we do there is that
in the fixed network--
in the proxy service-- we fetch
the pages and basically
just get the URL from
the mobile phone.
We fetch the page, we compress
it to a binary format, that we
send, then, over the wireless
network to the handset.
And currently we process
about 60 billion pages
per month on this.
We have many people in many
places far away from here,
like Russia, Indonesia,
India, places where
the bandwidth costs--
you pay per kilobyte, perhaps.
Or there's limited
connectivity.
Of course, there's never
limited connectivity
like here is there?
The other thing we do in this
space is Opera Turbo.
Opera Turbo is sort
of similar.
It's also a proxy service that
compresses, but unlike Opera
Mini, which compresses into a
binary format, Opera Turbo
just compresses by compressing
the HTML, the CSS, and the
images, much like you talked
about earlier here.
Opera Turbo is available from
the normal Opera desktop
application.
So if you download Opera
from opera.com,
you can turn on Turbo.
If it detects that you're on a
slow network, it will suggest,
perhaps you should turn me on.
And currently we have about five
billion page views per
month for Opera Turbo.
So it's significantly smaller
than Opera Mini, which has 60,
but still a lot of people
are using this.
And about a month ago,
we introduced
WebP into Opera Turbo.
We found out, after doing some
research, that WebP was the
perfect fit to encode the
images for Opera Turbo.
Here's a typical page.
You save about 50%
of the bandwidth.
It'd be interesting to see how
much Opera Turbo can compress
on top of the page speed module
that we saw there.
Whether those two will actually
really double the
performance or whether
they equal.
We should look into that.
But these are typical numbers
that we see, that you reduce
the size by 50% percent
and of course, then
time also goes down.
So images is an important
part of this.
And WebP we found out
was a perfect match.
If we take just a sample image
found on Flickr, when we do
the really hard compression
here, when we tried to go
really, really low,
we see that JPEG
has significant artifact.
It may be hard to see in this
projected mode here, but you
can see in the middle where JPEG
is used, we go down from
155 k to 8k.
We see significant artifact
around the head of the turtle,
for example.
Whereas in WebP, which
is even lower--
it's down to only 5kb--
we don't see those artifacts.
Now, this may be he's slightly
unfair to JPEG because the
original comes across
as a JPEG from the
first place, right?
So when you do another JPEG, it
seems like you get really
weird block effects when
these things double up.
And that may be one reason why
WebP is performing so well.
But so be it.
It works well, gives us
better compression.
And here's another one.
Again, we see that we have
strong artifact in the middle
image, whereas WebP gives
us better looking pages.
Now here's the colleague
of mine, Charles.
He's chief standards
officer at Opera.
And also I think the WebP
looks the best here.
If you look at the one
to the right, you see
his wrinkles there?
They they kind of disappeared.
So if you want to look beautiful
on screen, perhaps
WebP is the image
format to use.
Is this something you
put into decoder?
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Very good.
Now, the uses of WebP that's
we've seen, both in the Apache
module and in Opera Turbo,
that's where things are being
applied automatically.
I think there's still a time
to go before you can start
actually putting WebP images
on the web in your pages.
Because if you do so, it's
going to be disruptive.
Because most browsers will
not be able to see
those images yet.
If you use Opera or if you use
Chrome, you can go to the
gallery and it shows up.
But most other browsers will
not be able to show that.
So there will be a time.
And we had the same thing happen
when we introduced PNG
some years ago.
It takes a while before
browsers catch up.
I hope the other browsers will
catch up and add support for
WebP, just like they should
all support WebM as well.
But until they do, you shouldn't
really exclude users
by relying on this
being available.
As a web community, we need to
make sure that our webpages
work in most browsers
and most devices.
And I think that's also an
encouragement to Google.
I have to admit, at Opera we
have some problem with some of
the more experimentive Google
services that come out.
You're not always good at
testing in all cases.
So I encourage testing
to every one of us.
We need to make this web thing
work, we can't make it work
for half the people,
half the browsers.
We need to make it work
for everything.
That's one of the strengths
of the web, and I
hope that will continue.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD RABBAT: So we have time
for questions, if you
have any questions.
OK, go ahead.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
Question for Joshua, actually.
Two things.
We're using Rackspace cloud,
and we pay on a
compute-cycle basis.
How would using mod_pagespeed
affect compute cycle usage?
And also, when you're doing
combined requests off of a
CDN, would that affect-- when
you have multiple CDNs serving
the same content and you append
them for your CSS
requests, for instance--
would there be a performance
gain/loss?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: So the first
question is about the compute
costs associated with
mod_pagespeed.
And I should point that
mod_pagespeed uses a lot of
caching internally.
So although we are doing image
compression and image
resizing, et cetera, that's
really the only
compute-intensive thing
that we do.
But we cache the results, and
we only do that once.
So we think that amortized over
your entire site, it will
not be measurable.
But also please take into
account if you pay for
bandwidth or requests, you'll
be serving a lot less bytes
and a lot less requests
with mod_pagespeed.
Your second question is about
buying resources and CDNs.
And we support CDNs, we
support multi-server
configurations.
I'm not sure I entirely
understand your question.
Mod_pagespeed benefits CDNs
by making more resources
cacheable at the edge.
So it's, in general, a win.
And we enabled this because if
you remember, on the combined
CSS slide, the link name for the
combined CSS file encodes
all the information you need
to reproduce the result.
Which is why multi-server
is not a problem.
I hope that answers
your question.
Howdy.
So one of the big reasons that
PNG was so able to displace
GIF in many fields is that it
was not patent-encumbered.
And VP8 has, among other things,
not exactly been
forthcoming with complete
documentation for the format,
as is available for
JPEG and PNG.
And also the guarantee of not
being patent-encumbered is
still a little bit shaky, to
the point where VP8 simply
isn't available destroys
the valuable freedom
for Dora, for example.
So while I appreciate the
attempt to displace JPEG, now
that JPEG is actually
patent-free-- the patents
expired four or five
years ago--
how is the WebP team planning on
addressing patent concerns.
RICHARD RABBAT: So I'm not a
lawyer, so I won't be talking
about a patent.
But you are welcome to
talk to our lawyers
about patent issues.
With respect to documentation,
I'll give you that we also
really lack on documentation.
We try our hardest,
but at some point
we don't have enough--
it would be great if you can
contribute documentation.
I don't understand VP8 because
there's no VP8 documentation
available for me to understand
it from.
RICHARD RABBAT: So we've been
doing a lot of work on
documentation, so we have
updated a lot of
documentation on VP8.
And I can certainly point to the
people that are working on
the VP8 documentation.
If there's any specific
feedback, we can definitely
make sure that we cover it.
Are there plans to submit a
formal specification in the
manner of PNG to relevant
working groups for review?
RICHARD RABBAT: So I'm not the
product manager for VP8, so I
don't know exactly.
I know we have submitted an
informational RFC to document
what we do.
I don't know of the other
forward plans.
Fine, thank you.
So, does mod_pagespeed concept
change the way we should
approach design?
Should I have the designers now
producing all the pages
and putting the original art in
high quality large size and
breaking up the JavaScripts,
making no effort to do manual
optimization?
Because then the machine
optimizers could do a much
better job at that?
RICHARD RABBAT: Please don't.
I'll start with that.
We've seen a lot of HTML
files that lie to us.
And for many reasons, we
can't optimize them.
When somebody tells us what MIME
type that file is, for
example, is it's actually the
wrong MIME type, that's one of
the examples.
The importance of mod_pagespeed
is that in many
cases, you don't have the cycles
to actually redo all
the designs.
For example, every time you
change your UI layout, you
want to go and make every
image change.
And you want to be careful about
the use of your front
end engineers for that.
And I'll let Josh
answer as well.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Sure.
I don't think that there's a
need to do a complete 180
degree turn in how you do your
design of your webpages.
But it offers you the
opportunity to gradually
consider maintainability and
efficiency of your design
process, and let machines take
care of the processes.
So you could get there, but as
always, I would recommend
taking it one step at a time.
This may be a silly question,
it made be enabled already,
but you're speaking of getting
mod_pagespeed enabled on
different hosts and different
servers and getting it built
into different stacks.
It seems to me that Google is
perfectly poised to do this,
considering it has its own stack
in Google App Engine.
Is mod_pagespeed available
for App Engine?
Is it going to be available
Does it even apply
to App Engine?
RICHARD RABBAT: It is, I think,
the third bug that's
open on our issues list today.
For App Engine, it
is currently not
enabled in App Engine.
We've talked to the team,
they're very excited.
We're excited about potentially
providing it, but
we have not done any immediate
work on this.
We want to first focus on
stabilizing the technology,
making sure that we gets
the best out of it.
And benzes then deployments with
other servers as well.
One of the big questions, as
well, was how about EngineX?
How about Apache on Windows?
How about this?
Right now we're focused on the
core technology, and we'll
look at other things
in the future.
Thank you.
I think you actually just
answered my question.
We have seen a lot of success
with EngineX as a front end in
front of Apache, acting
as a reverse proxy.
It would be really great to
implement some of these
techniques on that
level instead.
So that's something that is on
the roadmap at some point?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: I stick EngineX
in front of Apache.
We've seen deployments where
EngineX is a front end and
Apache with mod_pagespeed
enabled is the back end, and
that should work great.
OK.
Yeah, thank you.
Can you talk to the
applicability of mod_pagespeed
and WebP or similar tools to
smartphones and tablets today
or in the future?
RICHARD RABBAT: For
mod_pagespeed, every time you
browse a page, you're going to
see a faster experience.
One of the really cool things
about mod_pagespeed is that it
reduces the number of
roundtrips you make.
And the roundtrip on a mobile
device is a couple of seconds
at some point.
So it's a very helpful tool for
a wireless and 3G and 4G
browsing experience.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah, I'll add
that mobile best practice are
different then desktop best
practices, in terms of
delivering the best
web experience.
And one of the things that we
get the opportunity to do in
mod_pagespeed is deliver an
experience customized to the
user agent, because we have a
stack that we pay a lot of
attention to on a daily basis,
that gets to see the user
agent and then decide
what to do.
So for example, today we do
image inlining only on
browsers that we know
to support it.
And so, the image inlining is
automatic and it works.
It doesn't leave
anybody behind.
That's kind of also the vision
with WebP, is that we can
transcode to WebP for browsers
that don't yet support it.
But for browsers that do, you
would get WebP automatically
for free without having to.
So along those same lines,
being able to have a
server-side decision about how
to render the webpage is only
going to benefit mobile.
Have we gotten everything that
we want out of mobile
experience, out of mod_pagespeed
yet?
No, we're still working
on that.
I work in organization I think
that has a fairly typical
workflow, in that we have a
centrally hosted content
management system which writes
out static assets to a CDN.
So we don't have control over
the buildout of the technology
at the CDN, but we
would like to--
for static assets such as CSS
and JS files, we run a manual
compression script before
pushing out.
For images however, we don't
have anything in place,
essentially.
Are there standalone
components?
Are there ways of ripping out
the image compression
components of this and running
that against our asses before
we push to CDN?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: So I guess the
point of mod_pagespeed is not
that we have new or unique image
processing capabilities.
Under the hood, actually
it's OpenCV.
ImageMagick is another good
engine that a lot of people
use when they're doing
this kind of
manual compression step.
The point of mod_pagespeed is
to save you the effort of
having to manage that
flow yourself.
But given that you have that
flow and you want to keep
doing it, something like
ImageMagick or other tools
like that are probably the best
bet for doing standalone
image compression.
RICHARD RABBAT: I think he was
talking about further out
where you have the HTML content
and you want to figure
out how the image should
be optimized
for that HTML content.
Yeah, there's a number
of touch points.
There's always, especially in
fairly large sites, you can
optimize at the CDN, you
can optimize before
you push to the CDN.
You could do some smart
edge-level page caching.
We've always taken a very simple
approach of, compress
everything, pull out all the
white space, pull out all the
comments, compress the graphics
as much as we can.
Prior to pushing out to the
CDN, and eliminate steps.
So I've see things like Yahoo
smush it, where you can upload
a bunch of images, they come
back looking exactly the same
but much smaller.
What I would love is an API that
we upload image, we send
the image to the API, the API
comes back with an optimized
lossless version of that
image, and then we
push it to the CDN.
If you're into custom
development.
RICHARD RABBAT: So we actually
have something that's on the
pagespeed online API part which
allows you to score the
page against the pagespeed's
rules.
We currently are going to give
you back results and tell you
what you could have
done better.
That's an interesting request
that we'll take into
consideration.
Thanks.
Hi, you mentioned that the
time to first byte on
mod_pagespeed is slightly
increased because of the
processing it does and some of
the optimization that applies.
Could some of that stuff
be done offline in a
pre-processing step?
Say, before I deploy
my resources?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's
a great question.
Of course, all those things
could be done, but they have
not yet been done.
But for the majority of
websites, we've taken kind of
a conservative approach to HTML
and assumed that it's
fairly dynamic and often
personalized to the user so
that caching HTML on the server
side is something that
would not be our default
behavior.
However, on the resource
optimization side,
we already do that.
Because we cache any
rewritten resource.
So when I talked about that
overhead or that time to first
byte, that's generally from
running it through the HTML
filter, because we don't
cache the HTML.
But we cache all of the
rewritten images and CSS files
so we don't have to redo
those every time.
Thank you.
RICHARD RABBAT: Thank
you all for coming.
I think a lot of people are
going to break for lunch now,
so we're keeping you away from
your food, so please go ahead.